fue durante la tarde del domingo cuando
el buque htms sukotay presentó problemas
debido a Los Fuertes vientos agua de mar
cayó en sus sistemas operativos
deshabilitándolos sin electricidad y el
barco captando agua la tripulación
perdió el control del mismo tomando una
inclinación de casi 90 grados Quienes se
encontraban a bordo se colocaron
chalecos salvavidas y esperaron por
ayuda en principio la armada tailandesa
trató de ayudar mediante el uso de
máquinas de bombeo móviles para
descargar el agua Pero el clima
dificultó la tarea y el barco se hundió
poco antes de la medianoche el buque de
guerra había estado patrullando a 20
millas de la costa del distrito de
panzapán Aparentemente para ayudar a
cualquier barco de pesca que pudiese
presentar problemas muchos marineros que
conformaban una tripulación de 106
miembros han sido rescatados hasta ahora
con la ayuda de un barco de la armada y
helicópteros sin embargo docenas siguen
desaparecidos tuviste que nadar en el
agua por un rato el rescate tomó tres
horas no se pudo acercar al barco debido
a las olas de cuántos metros Serán las
olas las pueden haber sido de unos tres
metros cuando el barco se hundió saltate
de inmediato Cuando comenzó a hundirse
salte de inmediato el htms sukotay se
construyó en Estados Unidos y fue puesto
en servicio en 1987 según el Instituto
naval de Estados Unidos mientras
continúa la operación de búsqueda y
rescate se advierte a otros barcos para
que permanezcan en tierra después de las
inclementes condiciones climáticas de
los Últimos Días